MICHALE FEE: OK, let's
go ahead and get started.
All right, so today, we're
going to continue talking about
feed-forward neural networks,
and we're going to keep working
on some interesting
aspects of linear algebra--
matrix transformations.
We're going to introduce a
new idea from linear algebra,
the idea of basis sets.
We're going to describe some
interesting and important
properties of basis sets,
such as linear independence.
And then we're going to end with
just a very simple formulation
of how to change between
different basis sets.
So let me explain
a little bit more,
motivate a little bit more
why we're doing these things.
So as people, as animals,
looking out at the world,
we are looking at
high-dimensional data.
We have hundreds of millions of
photoreceptors in our retina.
Those data get compressed
down into about a million
nerve fibers that go through
our optic nerve up to our brain.
So it's a very
high-dimensional data set.
And then our brain unpacks
that data and tries
to make sense of it.
And it does that by
passing that data
through layers of
neural circuits
that make transformations.
And we've talked about how in
going from one layer of neurons
to another layer
of neurons, there's
a feed-forward projection
that essentially
does what looks like a
matrix multiplication, OK?
So that's one of the
reasons why we're
trying to understand what
matrix multiplications do.
Now, we talked about some of
the matrix transformations
that you can see when you
do a matrix multiplication.
And one of those was a rotation.
Matrix multiplications
can implement rotations.
And rotations are very
important for visualizing
high-dimensional data.
So this is from a website
at Google research,
where they've implemented
different viewers
for high-dimensional data, ways
of taking high-dimensional data
and reducing the dimensionality
and then visualizing
what that data looks like.
And one of the
most important ways
that you visualize
high-dimensional data
is by rotating it and looking
at it from different angles.
And what you're
doing when you do
that is you take this
high-dimensional data,
you rotate it,
and you project it
into a plane, which is what
you're seeing on the screen.
And you can see that
you get a lot out
of looking at
different projections
and different
rotations of data sets.
Also, when you're
zooming in on the data,
that's another matrix
transformation.
You can stretch
and compress and do
all sorts of different
things to data.
Now, one of the cool
things is that when
we study the brain
to try to figure out
how it does this really cool
process of rotating data
through its
transformations that are
produced by neural networks,
we record from lots of neurons.
There's technology
now where you can
image from thousands, or even
tens of thousands, of neurons
simultaneously.
And again, it's this really
high-dimensional data
set that we're looking
at to try to figure out
how the brain works.
And so in order to
analyze those data,
we try to build programs
or machines that
act like the brain in order
to understand the data that we
collect from the brain.
It's really cool.
So it's kind of fun.
As neuroscientists, we're
trying to build a brain
to analyze the data that
we collect from the brain.
All right, so the cool thing
is that the math that we're
looking at right now and
the kinds of neural networks
that we're looking at
right now are exactly
the kinds of math
and neural networks
that you use to
explain the brain
and to look at data in very
powerful ways, all right?
So that's what
we're trying to do.
So let's start by coming back
to our two-layer feed-forward
network and looking
in a little bit more
detail about what it does.
OK, so I introduced the idea,
this two-layer feed-forward
network.
We have an input layer that
has a vector of firing rates,
a firing rate that describes
each of those input neurons,
a vector of firing rates.
That, again, is
a list of numbers
that describes the firing rate
of each neuron in the output
layer.
And the connections
between these two layers
are a bunch of synapses,
synaptic weights,
that we can use to calculate
to transform the firing
rates at the input layer into
the firing rates at the output
layer.
So let's look in a little
bit more detail now
at what that collection
of weights looks like.
So we describe it as a matrix.
That's called the weight matrix.
The matrix has in it a
number for the weight
from each of the input neurons
to each of the output neurons.
The rows are a vector
of weights onto each
of the output neurons.
And we'll see in
a couple of slides
that the columns are the set of
weights from each input neuron
to all the output neurons.
A row of this weight matrix
is a vector of weights
onto one of the output neurons.
All right, so we can
compute the firing rates
of the neurons in
our output layer
for the case of linear
neurons in the output layer
simply as a matrix
product of this weight
vector times the vector
of input firing rates.
And that matrix
multiplication gives us
a vector that describes the
firing rates of the output
layer.
So let me just go through
what that looks like.
If we define a column vector
of firing rates of each
of the output neurons,
we can write that
as the weight matrix times the
column vector of the firing
rates of the input layer.
We can calculate the firing
rate of the first neuron
in the output layer
as the dot product
of that row of the weight
matrix with that vector
of firing rates, OK?
And that gives us the
firing rate. v1 is then
W of a equals 1 dot u.
That is one particular
way of thinking
about how you're calculating
the firing rates in the output
layer.
And it's called the dot
product interpretation
of matrix multiplication,
all right?
Now, there's a different
sort of complementary way
of thinking about
what happens when
you do this matrix
product that's also
important to
understand, because it's
a different way of thinking
about what's going on.
We can also think about the
columns of this weight matrix.
And we can think about
the weight matrix
as a collection
of column vectors
that we put together
into matrix form.
So in this particular
network here,
we can write down this
weight matrix, all right?
And you can see that
this first input
neuron connects to output neuron
one, so there's a one there.
The first input neuron
connects to output neuron two,
so there's a one there.
The first input neuron does not
connect to output neuron three,
so there's a zero there, OK?
All right.
So the columns of
the weight matrix
represent the pattern
of projections from one
of the input neurons to
all of the output neurons.
All right, so let's
just take a look at what
would happen if only one of
our input neurons was active
and all the others were silent.
So this neuron is active.
What would the output
vector look like?
What would the pattern
of firing rates
look like for the output
neurons in this case?
Anybody?
It's straightforward.
It's not a trick question.
[INAUDIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: So--
MICHALE FEE: If this neuron
is firing and these weights
are all one or zero.
AUDIENCE: The one neuron, a--
MICHALE FEE: Yes?
This--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, [INAUDIBLE].
MICHALE FEE: --would
fire, this would fire,
and that would not fire, right?
Good.
So you can write that out
as a matrix multiplication.
So the firing rate
vector, in this case,
would be the dot product of
this with this, this with this,
and that with that.
And what you would see is
that the output firing rate
vector would look like this
first column of the weight
matrix.
So the output vector
would look like 1,
1, 0 if only the first
neuron were active.
So you can think of the
output firing rate vector
as being a contribution
from neuron one--
and that contribution
from neuron one
is simply the first column
of the weight matrix--
plus a contribution
from neuron two,
which is given by the
second column of the weight
matrix, and a contribution
from input neuron three,
which is given by the third
column of the weight matrix,
OK?
So you can think of the
output firing rate vector
as being a linear
combination of a contribution
from the first
neuron, a contribution
from the second neuron,
and a contribution
from the third neuron.
Does that make sense?
It's a different way
of thinking about it.
In the dot product
interpretation,
we're asking, what is the--
we're summing up
all of the weights
onto neuron one
from those synapses.
We're summing up all the
weights onto neuron two
from those synapses and summing
up all the weights onto neuron
three from those synapses.
So we're doing it one
output neuron at a time.
In this other interpretation
of this matrix multiplication,
we're doing something different.
We're asking, what is the
contribution to the output
from one of the input neurons?
What is the contribution to
the output from another input
neuron?
And what is the
contribution to the output
from yet another input neuron?
Does that makes sense?
OK.
All right, so we have
a linear combination
of contributions from each
of those input neurons.
And that's called the outer
product interpretation.
I'm not going to explain right
now why it's called that,
but that's how
that's referred to.
So the output pattern
is a linear combination
of contributions.
OK, so let's take a look at
the effect of some very simple
feed-forward networks, OK?
So let's just look
at a few examples.
So if we have a
feed forward-- this
is sort of the simplest
feed-forward network.
Each neuron in the
input layer connects
to one neuron in the output
layer with a weight of one.
So what is the weight
matrix of this network?
AUDIENCE: Identity.
MICHALE FEE: It's
the identity matrix.
And so the firing rate
of the output layer
will be exactly the same as
the firing rates in the input
layer, OK?
So there's the weight matrix,
which is just the identity
matrix, the firing rate.
And the output layer is
just the identity matrix
times the firing rate
of the input layer.
And so that's equal to
the input firing rate, OK?
All right, let's take a
slightly more complex network,
and let's make each one of
those weights independent.
They're not all
just equal to one,
but they're scaled
by some constant--
lambda 1, lambda
2, and lambda 3.
The weight matrix
looks like this.
It's a diagonal matrix,
where each of those weights
is on the diagonal.
And in that case, you can
see that the output firing
rate is just this diagonal
matrix times the input firing
rate.
And you can see that the
output firing rate is just
the input firing rate where each
component of the input firing
rate is scaled by some constant.
Pretty straightforward.
Let's take a look at a case
where the weight matrix now
corresponds to a
rotation matrix, OK?
So we're going to let the weight
matrix look like this rotation
matrix that we talked
about on Tuesday, where
are the diagonal elements are
cosine of sum rotation angle,
and the off-diagonal elements
are plus and minus sine
of the rotation angle.
So you can see that this
weight matrix corresponds
to this network, where the
projection from input neuron
one to output neuron
one is cosine phi.
Input neuron two to output
neuron two is cosine phi.
And then these cross-connections
are a plus and minus sine phi.
OK, so what does that do?
So we can see that the output
firing rate vector is just
a product of this rotation
matrix times the input firing
rate vector.
And you can write down
each component like that.
All right, so what does that do?
So let's take a
particular rotation angle.
We're going to take a
rotation angle of pi
over 4, which is 45 degrees.
That's what the weight
matrix looks like.
And we can do that
multiplication
to find that the output firing
rate vector looks like--
one of the neurons
has a firing rate
that looks like the sum of
the two input firing rates,
and the other output
neuron has a firing rate
that looks like the difference
between the two input firing
rates.
And if you look
at what this looks
like in the space of
firing rates of the input
layer and the output layer,
we can see what happens, OK?
So what we'll often
do when we look
at the behavior
of neural networks
is we'll make a
plot of the firing
rates of the different
neurons in the network.
And what we'll often do for
simple feed-forward networks,
and we'll also do this
for recurrent networks,
is we'll plot the input firing
rates as in the plane of u1
and u2.
And then we can plot the output
firing rates in the same plane.
So, for example, if we
have an input state that
looks like u1 equals u2,
it will be some point
on this diagonal line.
We can then plot the
output firing rate
on this plane, v1 versus v2.
And what will the output
firing rate look like?
What will the firing rate of
v1 look like in this case?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Yeah let's
say this is one and one.
So what will the firing rate
of this neuron look like?
[INAUDIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: What's that?
MICHALE FEE: So the
firing rate of v1
is just this quantity
right here, right?
So it's u1 plus u2, right?
So it's like 1
plus 1 over root 2.
So it will be big.
What will the firing rate
of neuron v2 look like?
It'll be u2 minus u1, which is?
AUDIENCE: Zero.
MICHALE FEE: Zero.
So it will be over here, right?
So it will be that input
rotated by 45 degrees.
And input down here--
so the firing rate of the one
will be the sum of those two.
Those two inputs
are both negative.
So v1 for this input
will be big and negative.
And v2 will be the
difference of u1 and u2,
which for anything
on this line is?
AUDIENCE: Zero.
MICHALE FEE: Zero.
OK.
And so that input will
be rotated over to here.
So you can think
of it this way--
any input in this space of
u1 and u2, in the output
will be just rotate by, in this
case, it's minus 45 degrees.
So that's clockwise,
are the minus rotations.
So you can just predict the
output firing rates simply
by taking the input
firing rates in this plane
and rotating them
by minus 45 degrees.
All right, any
questions about that?
It's very simple.
So this little neural
network implements
rotations of this input space.
That's pretty cool.
Why would you want a
network to do rotations?
Well, this solves
exactly the problem
that we were
working on last time
when we were talking about
our perceptron, where we were
trying to classify stimuli
that could not be separated
in one dimension,
but rather, can
be separated in two dimensions.
So if we have
different categories--
dogs and non-dogs--
that can be viewed along
different dimensions--
how furry they are--
but can't be separated--
the two categories can't be
separated from each other
on the basis of just one
dimension of observation.
So in this case, what we want to
do is take this base of inputs
and rotate it into a new what
we'll call a new basis set
so that now we can take the
firing rates of these output
neurons and use
those to separate
these different categories
from each other.
Does that make sense?
OK, so let me show you a
few more examples of that.
So this is one way to
think about what we
do when we do color vision, OK?
So you know that we have
different cones in our retina
that are sensitive to
different wavelengths.
Most colors are combinations
of those wavelengths.
So if we look at the
activity of, let's say,
a cone that's sensitive to
wavelength one and the activity
in a cone that's sensitive to
wavelength two, we might see--
and then we look
around the world.
We'll see a bunch
of different objects
or a bunch of
different stimuli that
activate those two different
cones in different ratios.
And you might imagine that this
axis corresponds to, let's say,
how much red there
is in a stimulus.
This axis corresponds
to how much green
there is in a stimulus.
But let's say that you're
in an environment where
there's some cloud of
contribution of red and green.
So what would this direction
correspond to in this cloud?
This direction corresponds
to more red and more green.
What would that correspond to?
AUDIENCE: Brown.
MICHALE FEE: So what I'm
trying to get at here
is that the sum of
those two is sort
of the brightness of
the object, right?
Something that has little
red and little green
will look the same color
as something that has
more red and more green, right?
But what's different
about those two stimuli
is that the one's
brighter than the other.
The second one is brighter
than the first one.
But this dimension
corresponds to what?
Differences in the ratio
of those two colors, right?
Sort of changes in the different
[AUDIO OUT] wavelengths,
and that corresponds to color.
So if we can take
this base of stimuli
and rotate it such that
one axis corresponds
to the sum of the two colors
and the other axis corresponds
to the difference
of the two colors,
then this axis will tell
you how bright it is,
and this axis will tell you what
the hue is, what the color is.
Does that makes sense?
So there's a simple
case of where
taking a rotation of a inputs
base, of a set of sensors,
will give you
different information
than you would get if you
just had one of those stimuli.
If you were to just look at
the activity of the cone that's
giving you a red
signal, if one object
has more activity
in that cone, you
don't know whether that
other object is just brighter
or if it's actually more
red, that looked red.
Does that makes sense?
So doing a rotation gives
us signals in single neurons
that carries useful information.
It can disambiguate different
kinds of information.
All right, so we can use
that simple rotation matrix
to perform that
kind of separation.
So brightness and color.
Here's another example.
I didn't get to talk about this
in this class, but there are--
so barn owls, they can very
exquisitely localize objects
by sound.
So they hunt, essentially,
at night in the dark.
They can hear a mouse
scurrying around in the grass.
They just listen to
that sound, and they
can tell exactly where it
is, and then they dive down
and catch the mouse.
So how did they do that?
Well, they used
timing differences
to tell which way the sound
is coming from side to side,
and they use
intensity differences
to tell which way the sound
is coming from up and down.
Now, how do you use
intensity differences?
Well, one of their
ears, their right ear
pointed slightly upwards.
And their left ear is
pointed slightly downwards.
So when they hear a sound
that's slightly louder
in the right ear and slightly
softer in the left ear,
they know that it's coming
from up above, right?
And if it's the
other way around,
if it's slightly louder
in the left ear and softer
in the right ear, they know it's
coming from below horizontal.
And it's extremely
precise system, OK?
So here's an example.
So if they're sitting
there listening
to the intensity, the amplitude
of the sound in the left ear
and the amplitude of the
sound in the right ear,
some sounds will be up here with
high amplitude in both ears.
Some sounds will be
over here, with more
amplitude in the right ear and
less amplitude in the left ear.
What does this
dimension correspond to?
That dimension corresponds to?
AUDIENCE: Proximity.
MICHALE FEE:
Proximity or, overall,
the loudness of
the sound, right?
And what does this
dimension correspond to?
AUDIENCE: Direction.
MICHALE FEE: The difference
in intensity corresponds
to the elevation of the sound
relative to the horizontal.
All right?
So, in fact, what happens
in the owl's brain
is that these two signals
undergo a rotation to produce
activity in some neurons
that's sensitive to the overall
loudness and activity
in other neurons that's
sensitive to the difference
between the intensity
of the two sounds.
It's a measure of the
elevation of the sounds.
All right, so this
kind of rotation matrix
is very useful for
projecting stimuli
into the right dimension so
that they give useful signals.
All right, so let's come back
to our matrix transformations
and look in a little
bit more detail
about what kinds
of transformations
you can do with matrices.
So we talked about
how matrices can do
stretch, compression, rotation.
And we're going to talk about
a new kind of transformation
that they can do.
So you remember we talked about
how a matrix multiplication
implements a transformation
from one set of vectors
into another set of vectors?
And the inverse of that
matrix transforms back
to the original
set of vectors, OK?
So you can make
a transformation,
and then you can undo
that transformation
by multiplying by the
inverse of the matrix.
OK, so we talked about different
kinds of transformations
that you can do.
So if you take the
identity matrix
and you make a
small perturbation
to both of the diagonal
elements, the same perturbation
to both diagonal
elements, you're basically
taking a set of vectors
and you're stretching them
uniformly in all directions.
If you make a perturbation
to just one of the components
of the identity matrix,
you can take the data
and stretch it in one
direction or stretch it
in the other direction.
If you add something
to the first component
and subtract something
from the second component,
you can stretch in one
direction and compress
in another direction.
We talked about reflections and
inversions through the origin.
These are all
transformations that are
produced by diagonal matrices.
And the inverse of
those diagonal matrices
is just one over the
diagonal elements.
OK, we also talked
about rotations
that you can do with
this rotation matrix.
And then the inverse
of the rotation matrix
is, basically, you compute the
inverse of a rotation matrix
simply by computing
the rotation matrix
with a minus sign for
this, using the negative
of the rotation angle.
And we also talked about
how a rotation matrix--
for a rotation
matrix, the inverse
is also equal to the transpose.
And the reason is
that rotation matrices
have this antisymmetry, where
the off-diagonal elements have
the opposite sign.
One of the things we
haven't talked about is--
so we talked about how
this kind of matrix
can produce a stretch along
one dimension or a stretch
along the other
dimension of the vectors.
But one really important
kind of transformation
that we need to understand is
how you can produce stretches
in an arbitrary direction, OK?
So not just along the x-axis or
along the y-axis, but along any
arbitrary direction.
And the reason we need
to know how that works
is because that formulation
of how you write down a matrix
to stretch data in any
arbitrary direction
is the basis of a lot of
really important data analysis
methods, including
principal component
analysis and other methods.
So I'm going to
walk you through how
to think about making
stretches in data
in arbitrary dimensions.
OK, so here's what we're
going to walk through.
Let's say we have
a set of vectors.
I just picked--
I don't know, what is that--
20 or so random vectors.
So I just called a random
number generator 20 times
and just picked
20 random vectors.
And we're going to figure out
how to write down a matrix that
will transform
that set of vectors
into another set of vectors that
stretched along some arbitrary
axis.
Does that make sense?
So how do we do that?
And remember, we know
how to do two things.
We know how to stretch a set
of vectors along the x-axis.
We know how to stretch
vectors along the y-axis,
and we know how to
rotate a set of vectors.
So we're just going
to combine those two
ingredients to produce this
stretch in an arbitrary
direction.
So now I've given
you the recipe--
or I've given you
the ingredients.
The recipe's pretty
obvious, right?
We're going to take this
set of initial vectors.
Good.
Lina?
AUDIENCE: You [INAUDIBLE].
That's it.
MICHALE FEE: Bingo.
OK, so we're going to take--
all right, so we're going to
rotate this thing 45 degrees.
We take this original
set of vectors.
We're going to--
OK, so first of
all, the first thing
we do when we want to
take a set of points
and stretch it along
an arbitrary direction,
we pick that angle that
we want to stretch it
on-- in this case, 45 degrees.
And we write down a rotation
matrix corresponding
to that rotation,
corresponding to that angle.
So that's the first thing we do.
So we've chosen 45
degrees as the angle
we want to stretch on.
So now we write down
a rotation matrix
for a 45-degree rotation.
Then what we're
going to do is we're
going to take that set
of points and we're
going to rotate it
by minus 45 degrees.
So how do we do that?
How do we take any one of those
vectors x and rotate it by--
so this that rotation
matrix is for plus 45.
How do we rotate that
vector by minus 45?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] multiply
it by the [INAUDIBLE]..
MICHALE FEE: Good.
Say it.
AUDIENCE: Multiply by
the inverse of that.
MICHALE FEE: Yeah, and
what's the inverse of a--
AUDIENCE: Transpose.
MICHALE FEE: Transpose.
So we don't have to go to Matlab
and use the inverse matrix
in inversion.
We can just do the transpose.
OK, so we take that vector and
we multiply it by transpose.
So that does a minus
45-degree rotation
of all of those points.
And then what do we do?
Lina, you said it.
Stretch it.
Stretch it along?
AUDIENCE: The x-axis?
MICHALE FEE: The x-axis, good.
What does that matrix
look like that does that?
Just give me-- yup?
AUDIENCE: 5, 0, 0, 1.
MICHALE FEE: Awesome.
That's it.
So we're going to stretch
using a stretch matrix.
So I use phi for
a rotation matrix,
and I use lambda for a
stretch matrix, a stretch
matrix along x or y.
Lambda is a diagonal
matrix, which always just
stretches or compresses
along the x or y direction.
And then what do we do?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Good.
By multiplying by?
By this.
Excellent.
That's all.
So how do we write this down?
So, remember, here, we're sort
of marching through the recipe
from left to right.
When you write down matrices,
you go the other way.
So when you do matrix
multiplication,
you take your vector x and you
multiply it on the left side
by phi transpose.
And then you take that and you
multiply that on the left side
by lambda.
And then you take that.
That now gives you these.
And now to get the
final answer here,
you multiply again on
the left side by phi.
That's it.
That's how you produce
an arbitrary stretch--
a stretch or a
compression of a data
in an arbitrary
direction, all right?
You take the data, the vector.
You multiply it by a
rotation matrix transpose,
multiply it by a stretch
matrix, a diagonal matrix,
and you multiply it
by a rotation matrix.
Rotate, stretch, unrotate.
So let's actually do
this for 45 degrees.
So there's our rotation matrix--
1, minus 1, 1, 1.
The transpose is
1, 1, minus 1, 1.
And here's our stretch matrix.
In this case, it was
stretched by a factor of two.
So we multiply x by phi
transpose, multiply by lambda,
and then multiply by phi.
So we can now write that down.
If you just do
those three matrix
multiplications-- those two
matrix multiplications, sorry,
yes?
One, two.
Two matrix multiplications.
You get a single matrix
that when you multiply it by
x implements this stretch.
Any questions about that?
You should ask me now
if you don't understand,
because I want you to be able
to do this for an arbitrary--
so I'm going to
give you some angle,
and I'll tell you,
construct a matrix that
stretches data along a 30-degree
axis by a factor of five.
You should be able to
write down that matrix.
All right, so this is
what you're going to do,
and that's what that matrix will
look like, something like that.
Now, we can stretch these
data along a 45-degree axis
by some factor.
It's a factor of two here.
How do we go back?
How do we undo that stretch?
So how do you take the inverse
of a product of a bunch
of matrices like this?
So the answer is very simple.
If we want to take the inverse
of a product of three matrices,
what we do is we just--
it's, again, a product
of three matrices.
It's a product of the inverse
of those three matrices,
but you have to
reverse the order.
So if you want to find the
inverse of matrix A times B
times C, it's C inverse times
B inverse times A inverse.
And you can prove that that's
the right term as follows.
So ABC inverse times ABC should
be the identity matrix, right?
So let's replace this
by this result here.
So C inverse B inverse
A inverse times
ABC would be the
identity matrix.
And you can see that right
here, A inverse times A is i.
So you can get rid of that.
B inverse times B is i.
C inverse times C is i.
So we just proved that
that is the correct way
of taking the inverse of a
product of matrices, all right?
So the inverse of
this kind of matrix
that stretches data along
an arbitrary direction
looks like this.
It's phi transpose inverse
lambda inverse phi inverse.
So let's figure out what
each one of those things is.
So what is phi
transpose inverse,
where phi is a rotation matrix?
AUDIENCE: Just phi.
MICHALE FEE: Phi, good.
And what is phi inverse?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: [INAUDIBLE].
Good.
And lambda inverse we'll
get to in a second.
So the inverse of this
arbitrary rotated stretch matrix
is just another rotated
stretch matrix, right?
Where the lambda now has--
lambda inverse is just
given by the inverse of each
of those diagonal elements.
So it's super easy to
find the inverse of one
of these matrices that computes
this stretch in an arbitrary
direction.
You just keep the same phi.
It's just phi times some
diagonal matrix times
phi transpose, but the
diagonals are inverted.
Does that makes sense?
All right, so
let's write it out.
We're going to undo this
45-degree stretch that we just
did.
We're going to do it by
rotating, stretching by 1/2
instead of stretching by two.
So you can see that compresses
now along the x-axis.
And then we rotate
back, and we're back
to our original data.
Any questions about that?
It's really easy,
as long as you just
think through what you're doing
as you go through those steps,
all right?
Any questions about that?
OK.
Wow.
All right.
So you can actually
just write those down
and compute the
single matrix that
implements this compression
along that 45-degree axis, OK?
All right.
So let me just show
you one other example.
And I'll show you
something interesting
that happens if you construct
a matrix that instead
of stretching along a
45-degree axis does compression
along a 45-degree axis.
So here's our original data.
Let's take that data and
rotate it by plus 45 degrees.
Multiplied by lambda, that
compresses along the x-axis
and then rotates by
minus 45 degrees.
So here's an example where we
can take data and compress it
along an axis of minus
45 degrees, all right?
So you can write this down.
So we're going to say
we're going to compress
along a minus 45 degree axis.
We write down phi of minus 45.
Notice that when you do this
compression or stretching,
there are different ways
you can do it, right?
You can take the data.
You can rotate it this way and
then squish along this axis.
Or you could rotate it this
way and squish along this axis,
right?
So there are choices
for how you do it.
But in the end,
you're going to end up
with the same matrix that
does all of those equivalent
transformations.
OK, so here we are.
We're going to write this out.
So we're writing
down a matrix that
produces this compression
along a minus 45-degree axis.
So there's 5 minus 45.
There's lambda, a
compression along the x-axis.
So here, it's 0.2001.
And here's the phi transpose.
So you write all that out, and
you get 0.6, 0.4, 0.4, 0.4.
Let me show you one more.
What happens if we accidentally
take this data, we rotate it,
and then we squish
the data to zero?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: It doesn't.
You can do either one.
Let me go back.
Let me just go back
to the very first one.
So here, we rotated
clockwise and then
stretched along the
x-axis and then unrotated.
We could have taken these
data, rotated counterclockwise,
stretched along the y-axis,
and then rotated back, right?
Does that make sense?
You'll still get
the same answer.
You'll still get the same
answer for this matrix here.
OK, now watch this.
What happens if we take
these data, we rotate them,
and then we compress
data all the way to zero?
So by compressing
the data to a line,
we're multiplying it by zero.
We put a zero in this element of
the stretch matrix, all right?
And what happens?
The data get compressed
right to zero, OK?
And then we can rotate back.
So we've taken these data.
We can write down a matrix
that takes those data
and squishes them to zero
along some arbitrary direction.
Now, can we take those data and
go back to the original data?
Can we write down
a transformation
that takes those and goes
back to the original data?
Why not?
AUDIENCE: Lambda
doesn't [INAUDIBLE]..
MICHALE FEE: Say it again.
AUDIENCE: Lambda
doesn't [INAUDIBLE]..
MICHALE FEE: Good.
What's another way
to think about that?
AUDIENCE: We've
lost [INAUDIBLE]..
MICHALE FEE: You've
lost that information.
So in order to go back from
here to the original data,
you have to have information
somewhere here that tells you
how far out to stretch it
again when you try to go back.
But in this case, we've
compressed everything
to a line, and so
there's no information
how to go back to
the original data.
And how do you know
if you've done this?
Well, you can take a look at
this matrix that you created.
So let's say somebody
gave you this matrix.
How would you tell
whether you could
back to the original data?
Any ideas?
Abiba?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Good.
You look at the determinant.
So if you calculate the
determinant of this matrix,
the determinant is zero.
And as soon as you see
a zero determinant,
you know right away
that you can't go back.
After you've made
this transformation,
you can't go back to
the original data.
And we're going to get into a
little more detail about why
that is and what that means.
And the reason here is that the
determinant of lambda is zero.
The determinant of
a product matrices
like this is the product
of the determinants.
And in this case, the
determinant of the lambda
matrix is zero, and so the
determinant of the product
is zero, OK?
All right, so now let's
talk about basis sets.
All right, so we can think of
vectors in abstract directions.
So if I hold my arm
out here and tell you
this is a vector--
there's the origin.
The vectors pointing
in that direction.
You don't need a
coordinate system
to know which way I'm pointing.
I don't need to tell
you my arm is pointing
80 centimeters in
that direction and 40
centimeters in that
direction and 10 centimeters
in that direction, right?
You don't need a
coordinate system
to know which way
I'm pointing, right?
But if I want to
quantify that vector so
that-- if you want to quantify
that vector so that you can
maybe tell somebody else
precisely which direction I'm
pointing, you need to write
down those numbers, OK?
So you can think of vectors
in abstract directions,
but if you want to actually
quantify it or write it down,
you need to choose
a coordinate system.
And so to do this,
you choose a set
of vectors, special
vectors, called a basis set.
And now we just say,
here's a vector.
How much is it pointing in
that direction, that direction,
and that direction?
And that's called a basis set.
So we can write
down our vector now
as a set of three numbers
that simply tell us
how far that vector
is overlapped
with three other vectors
that form the basis set.
So the standard
way of doing this
is to describe a vector as a
component in the x direction,
which is a vector 1, 1, 0, sort
of in the standard notation;
a component in the y
direction, which is 0,
1, 0; and a component in
the z direction, 0, 0, 1.
So we can write those vectors
as standard basis vectors.
The numbers x, y,
and z here are called
the coordinates of the vector.
And the vectors e1, e2, and e3
are called the basis vectors.
And this is how you
would write that down
for a three-dimensional
vector, OK?
Again, the little
hat here denotes
that those are unit vectors
that have a length one.
All right, so in order
to describe an arbitrary
vector in a space
of n real numbers,
Rn, the basis vectors each
need to have n numbers.
And in order to describe an
arbitrary vector in that space,
you need to have
n basis vectors.
You need to have--
in n dimensions, you need
to have n basis vectors,
and each one knows basis vectors
has to have n numbers in them.
So these vectors here--
1, 0, 0; 0, 1, 0; and 0, 0, 1--
are called the standard basis.
And each one of these values
has one element that's one
and the rest are zero.
That's the standard basis.
The standard basis
has the property
that any one of those vectors
dotted into itself is one.
That's because
they're unit vectors.
They have length one.
So i dot ei is the length
squared of the i-th vector.
And if the length is one, then
the length squared is one.
Each vector is orthogonal
to all the other vectors.
That means that each e1 dot e2
is zero, and e1 dot e3 is zero,
and e2 dot e3 is zero.
You can write down as e sub i
dot e sub j equals zero for i
not equal to j.
You can write all
of those properties
down in one equation--
e sub i dot e sub
j equals delta i j.
Delta i j is what's called
the Kronecker delta function.
The Kronecker delta function is
a one if i equals j and a zero
if i is not equal to j, OK?
So it's a very compact way
of writing down this property
that each vector
is a unit vector
and each vector is orthogonal
to all the other vectors.
And the set with that property
is called an off an orthonormal
basis set.
All right, now, the standard
basis is not the only basis--
sorry.
I'm trying to do
x, y, and z here.
So if you have x,
y, and z, that's
not the only
orthonormal basis set.
Any basis set that is a
rotation of those three vectors
is also an orthonormal basis.
Let's write down two other
orthogonal unit vectors.
We can write down our
vector v in this other basis
set as follows.
We just take our vector v.
We can plot the basis vectors
in this other basis.
And we can simply project v
onto those other basis vectors.
So we can project v onto f1,
and we can project v onto f2.
So we can write v as a sum of
a vector in the direction of f1
and a vector in the
direction of f2.
You can write down this vector
v in this different basis set
as a vector with two components.
This is two dimensional.
This is R2.
You can write it down as
a two-component vector--
v dot f1 and v dot f2.
So that's a simple intuition
for what [AUDIO OUT]
in two dimensions.
We're going to develop the
formalism for doing this
in arbitrary dimensions, OK?
And it's very simple.
All right, these
components here are
called the vector coordinates
of this vector basis f.
All right, now, basis
sets, or basis vectors,
don't have to be
orthogonal to each other,
and they don't
have to be normal.
They don't have
to be unit vector.
You can write down
an arbitrary vector
as a sum of
components that aren't
orthogonal to each other.
So you can write
down this vector v
as a sum of a component
here in the f1 direction
and a component in
the f2 direction,
even if f1 and f2 are not
orthogonal to each other
and even if they're
not unit vectors.
So, again, v is expressed
as a linear combination
of a vector in the f1
direction and a vector
in the f2 direction.
OK, so let's take a
vector and decompose it
into an arbitrary
basis set f1 and f2.
So v equals c1 f1 plus c2 f2.
The coefficients here are
called the coordinates
of the vector in this basis.
And the vector v sub f--
these numbers, c1 and c2, when
combined into this vector,
is called the coordinate
vector of v in the basis f1
and f2, OK?
Does that makes sense?
Just some terminology.
OK, so let's define
this basis, f1 and f2.
We just pick two vectors,
an arbitrary two vectors.
And I'll explain later that not
all choices of vectors work,
but most of them do.
So here are two vectors that
we can choose as a basis--
so 1, 3, which is sort of
like this, and minus 2, 1
is kind of like that.
And we're going to
write down this vector
v in this new basis.
So we have a vector v that's
3, 5 in the standard basis,
and we're going to rewrite it
in this new basis, all right?
So we're going to find the
vector coordinates of v
in the new basis.
So we're going to
do this as follows.
We're going to write v as a
linear combination of these two
basis vectors.
So c1 times f1--
1, 3-- plus c2 times f2--
minus 2, 1-- is equal to 3, 5.
That make sense?
So what is that?
That is just a system
of equations, right?
And what we're trying to
do is solve for c1 and c2.
That's it.
So we already did this
problem in the last lecture.
So we have this
system of equations.
We can write this down in the
following matrix notation.
F times vf-- vf is
just c1 and c2--
equals v. So there's F--
1, 3; minus 2, 1.
Those are our two basis vectors.
Times c1 c2-- the vector
c1, c2-- is equal to 3, 5.
And we solve for vf.
In other words, we
solve for c1 and c2
simply by multiplying v by
the inverse of this matrix F.
So the coordinate vector
in this new base is said
is just the old vector
times f inverse.
And what is f inverse?
F inverse is just a matrix
that has the basis vectors
as the columns of the matrix.
So the coordinates of this
vector in his new basis set
are given by f inverse times v.
We can find the inverse of f.
So if that's our f, we can
calculate the inverse of that.
Remember, you flip
the diagonal elements.
You multiply the
off-diagonals by minus 1,
and you divide by
the determinant.
So f inverse is this times v is
that, and v sub f is just 13/7
over minus 4/7.
So that's just a different
way of writing v.
So there's v in
the standard basis.
There's v in this
new basis, all right?
And all you do to go
from the standard basis
to any arbitrary new basis
is multiply the vector
by f inverse.
And when you're actually
doing this in Matlab,
this is really simple.
You just write down
a matrix F that has
the basis sets in the columns.
You just use the matrix
inverse function,
and then you multiply
that by the data matrix,
by the data vector.
All right, so I'm just
going to summarize again.
In order to find the coordinate
vector for v in this new basis,
you construct a matrix
F, whose columns
are just the elements
of the basis vectors.
So if you have
two basis vectors,
it's a two-- remember, each
of those basis vectors.
In two dimensions, there
are two basis vectors.
Each has two numbers, so
this is a 2 by 2 matrix.
In n dimensions, you
have n basis vectors.
Each of the basis
vectors has n numbers.
And so this matrix F is an
n by n matrix, all right?
You know that you can write down
v as this basis times v sub f.
You solve for v sub f by
multiplying both sides
by f inverse, all right?
That performs whats
called change of basis.
Now, that only works
if f has an inverse.
So if you're going to choose
a new basis to write down
your vector, you have to
be careful to pick one
that has an inverse, all right?
And I want to show
you what it looks
like when you pick a basis
that doesn't have an inverse
and what that means.
All right, and that gets to the
idea of linear independence.
All right, so, remember I said
that if in n dimensions, in Rn,
in order to have a basis in Rn,
you have certain requirements?
Not any vectors will work.
So let's take a look
at these vectors.
Will those work to describe an--
will that basis set work
to describe an arbitrary
vector in three dimensions?
No?
Why not?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] vectors,
so if you're [INAUDIBLE]..
MICHALE FEE: Right.
So the problem is in which
coordinate, which axis?
AUDIENCE: Z-axis.
MICHALE FEE: The z-axis.
You can see that you have zeros
in all three of those vectors,
OK?
You can't describe any
vector with this basis
that has a non-zero
component in the z direction.
And the reason is that
any linear combination
of these three vectors will
always lie in the xy plane.
So you can't describe
any vector here
that has a non-zero z
component, all right?
So what we say is that
this set of vectors
doesn't span all of R3.
It only spans the
xy plane, which
is what we call a
subspace of R3, OK?
OK, so let's take a look
at these three vectors.
The other thing to
notice is that you
can write any one
of these vectors
as a linear combination
of the other two.
So you can write f3
as a sum of f1 and f2.
The sum of those two vectors
is equal to that one.
You can write f2 as f3 minus f1.
So any of these vectors can be
written as a linear combination
of the others.
And so that set of vectors
is called linearly dependent.
And any set of linearly
dependent vectors cannot form
a basis.
And how do you know
if a set of vectors
that you choose for your
basis is linearly dependent?
Well, again, you just find the
determinant of that matrix.
And if it's zero, those
vectors are linearly dependent.
So what that corresponds to
is you're taking your data
and when you transform
it into a new basis,
if the determinant
of that matrix F
is zero, then what you're doing
is you're taking those data
and transforming them to a space
where they're being collapsed.
Let's say if you're
in three dimensions,
those data are being collapsed
onto a plane or onto a line,
OK?
And that means you can't undo
that transformation, all right?
And the way to tell whether
you've got that problem
is looking at the determinant.
All right, let me show
you one other cool thing
about the determinant.
There's a very simple
geometrical interpretation
of what the determinant is, OK?
All right, sorry.
So if f maps your
data onto a subspace,
then the mapping
is not reversible.
OK, so what does the
determinant correspond to?
Let's say in two dimensions,
if I have two orthogonal unit
vectors, you can
think of those vectors
as kind of forming a
square in this space.
Or in three dimensions, if I
have three orthogonal vectors,
you can think of those vectors
as defining a cube, OK?
And if there unit
vectors, then they
define a cube of volume one.
Here, you have the
square of area one.
So let's think about
this unit volume.
If I transform those two
vectors or those three vectors
in 3D space by a
matrix A, those vectors
get rotated and transformed.
They point in different
directions, and they define--
it's no longer a cube, but they
define some sort of rhombus,
OK?
You can ask, what is the
volume of that rhombus?
The volume of that rhombus
is just the determinant
of that matrix A.
So now what happens
if I have a cube in
three-dimensional space
and I multiply it by a
matrix that transforms it
into a rhombus that
has zero volume?
So let's say I have
those three vectors.
It transforms it into,
let's say, a square.
The volume of that square
in three dimensional space
is zero.
So what that means is I'm
transforming my vectors
into a space that
has zero volume
in the original dimensions, OK?
So I'm transforming things
from 3D into a 2D plane.
And what that means is
I've lost information,
and I can't go back.
OK, notice that a rotation
matrix, if I take this cube
and I rotate it, has
exactly the same volume
as it did before I rotated it.
And so you can always tell when
you have a rotation matrix,
because the determinant of
a rotation matrix is one.
So if you take a matrix A
and you find the determinant
and you find that the
determinant is one,
you know that you have
a pure rotation matrix.
What does it mean if the
determinant is minus one?
What it means is
you have a rotation,
but that one of the axes
is inverted, is flipped.
There's a mirror in there.
So you can tell if you
have a pure rotation
or if you have a rotation and
one of the axes is flipped.
Because in the pure rotation,
the determinant is one.
And in an impure rotation, you
have a rotation and a mirror
flip.
All right, and I just want to
make a couple more comments
about change of basis, OK?
All right, so let's choose
a set of basis vectors
for our new basis.
Let's write those
into a matrix F.
It's going to be our
matrix of basis vectors.
If the determinant
is not equal to zero,
then these vectors,
that set of vectors,
are linearly independent.
That means you cannot write one
of those vectors as a linear
combination of--
any one of those vectors
as a linear combination
of the others.
Those vectors form a complete
basis in that n dimensional
space.
The matrix F implements
a change of basis,
and you can go from
the standard basis to F
by multiplying your
vector by F inverse
to get the coordinate
vector and your new basis.
And you can go back from that
rotated or transformed basis
back to the coordinate basis
by multiplying by F, OK?
Multiply by F inverse
transforms to the new basis.
Multiplying by F
transforms back.
If that set of vectors is
an orthonormal basis, then--
OK, so let's take this
matrix F that has columns
that are the new basis vectors.
And let's say that those
form an orthonormal basis.
In that case, we can write
down-- so, in any case,
we can write down the transpose
of this matrix, F transpose.
And now the rows of that
matrix are the basis vectors.
Notice that if we multiply
F transpose times F,
we have basis vectors in
rows here and columns here.
So what is F transpose
F for the case
where these are
unit vectors that
are orthogonal to each other?
What is that product?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: It's what?
MICHALE FEE: Good.
Because F1 dot F1 is one.
F1 dot F2 is zero.
F2 dot F1 is zero,
and F2 dot F2 is 0.
So that's equal to the
identity matrix, right?
So F transpose equals F inverse.
If the inverse of a matrix
is just its transpose,
then that matrix is
a rotation matrix.
So F is just the
rotation matrix.
All right, now let's
see what happens.
So that means the inverse of
F is just this F transpose.
Let's do this coordinate--
let's [AUDIO OUT]
change of basis for this case.
So you can see that v sub f,
the coordinate vector in the new
basis, is F transpose
v. Here's F transpose--
the basis vectors
are in the rows--
times v. This is just v
dot F1, v dot F2, right?
So this shows how for
a orthonormal basis,
the transpose, which
is the inverse of F--
taking the transpose
of F times v
is just taking the
dot product of v
with each of the
basis vectors, OK?
So that ties it back to what we
were showing before about how
to do this change of basis, OK?
Just tying up those two
ways of thinking about it.
So, again, what
we've been developing
when we talk about
change of basis
are ways of rotating
vectors, rotating sets
of data, into
different dimensions,
into different basis
sets so that we
can look at data from
different directions.
That's all we're doing.
And you can see
that when you look
at data from different
directions, you can get--
some views of data, you have
a lot of things overlapping,
and you can't see them.
But when you rotate those
data, now, all of a sudden,
you can see things
clearly that used to be--
things get separated in some
views, whereas in other views,
things are kind of mixed up
and covering each other, OK?
And that's exactly what neural
networks are doing when they're
analyzing sensory stimuli.
They're doing that
kind of rotations
and untangling the
data to see what's
there in that
high-dimensional data, OK?
All right, that's it.